[Musique]
j'ai rencontré
réponds que je donnerai ma vie comme
parolier je disais que j'allais
journaliste août que j'ai des
professeurs de langues
[Musique]
quand le président de l'adf qui est
assis à côté de minutes d'affaires
culturelles ose écrire une lettre à ses
créateurs disant qu'on va acheter la
vitre de spectacteurs convainc les
droits d'auteur photo canal eu des fois
j'ai encore on fait tous du show
business
comment es tu
[Musique]
très très très bref aperçu de la
carrière de luc plamandon parolier 50
ans de carrière
près de 500 chansons les opéras rock des
comédies musicales
en fait les hommages se multiplient on
n'a qu'à penser à celui de la semaine
dernière aux francofolies qui sera
repris d'ailleurs cet été au festival
d'été de québec si vous voulez faire le
détour
des chansons qui ont été interprétés
c'était peut-être un peu la touche masi
magique de plamandon de décrire pour des
diane dufresne céline dion robert
charlebois combien d beaucoup de jeunes
chanteurs bonne journée avec le projet
de journal et d écouter on va revoir des
extraits de ces deux grandes comédies
musicales opéra rock d'abord starmania
et le protect c'est bon parce que
starmania célèbre ses 40 ans cette année
là le disque est paru il ya 40 ans notre
dame de paris ça fait 20 ans des oeuvres
qui continuent de témoigner de leur
temps le monde on est de passage au
québec loto-québec pour l'été sur la
fête de la musique les vois beaucoup de
spectacle alors lui quand vous regardez
un court extrait du reportage de france
2 qui vous rendent un hommage cette
semaine pour souligner les 40 à sa
manière
l'étude de starmania semble avoir été
composé hier
[Musique]
des mélodies restée célèbre au fil des
années on arrive en ville et de nouveaux
talents révélés comme daniel balavoine
c'est bien
ou la québécoise fabienne thibeault
ou les
quarante ans plus tard fabienne
thibeault se souvient de cette grande
scène intimidante du palais des congrès
sur laquelle elle a interprété son
personnage de la serveuse automate
imaginez le décor saut et vous avez les
quatre mêmes personnes je crois et je me
rappelle comme décor c'est ouvert
charles venu j'ai vu chacun et là j'ai
dit j'avance où je retourne au québec on
vous voit le paiement dont la avec
justement lui qui est michel berger
votre ami avec qui vous avez une union
magique avec lui pour starmania de
revoir ces images là quarante ans plus
tard d'avoir très entendre du bois de
d'entendre à bien de thibaut l origine
aussi pu la voir maintenant quelles
émotions ça bouffe est fait ça m'a suivi
effectivement toute ma vie depuis que
depuis 40 ans cette année
parce que tous les autres je veux pas
aller journée par une journée qui passe
sans que quelqu'un m'arrêtent dans la
rue pour me dire ah mon dieu vous m'avez
sauvé la vie vos chansons sont vraiment
ce système madoff terme à nos attentes
mais c'est toujours le mot star de
manioc qui revient ouais et il ya une
collègue qui m'a dit aujourd'hui sachant
que venait à l'émission elle avait 12
ans quand elle entendait la chanson la
serveuse automate a dit moi ça me donne
le goût de faire ce que je voulais
est ce qu'on pense à ce pouvoir là que
notre oeuvre a un impact aussi grand sur
la vie des gens à quoi bon on ne sait
pas quand on écrit une chanson surtout
des j'ai toujours été créé pour les
personnages vont jusqu'au bout j'ai
toujours écrit la vie des personnages
comme je pense je disais j'ai cru mais
pas ma vie publique ne met pas la vie
des interprètes ça avait choqué diane
dufresne que j sommet j'écrivais des
personnages pour pour diane non après
elle est devenue ce n'est pas un
personnage à partir de ces personnages
jamais mais il reste que c'est surtout
que de plume les légendes et criblé de
cliquer ou temps tout en ne le dise
merci dispo bravo une disent merci c'est
ça qui est beau et que ce qu'on pouvait
vous demander comme peut poser
aujourd'hui c'est ce que le monde est
important
robin de plus en plus mais bon c'est si
important de penser que qu'est-ce que ça
fait du bien aux gens mais pour être
avoir été visionnaire oui un peu parce
que la première phase ii dans le livret
de starmania c'est madame monsieur
bonsoir
le milliardaire constructeur de
gratte-ciel 0 janvier vient de poser sa
candidature à la présidence de
l'occident ça commence comme ça et là il
ya les relais des zones arrivée qui
viennent casser la
et c'est le terrorisme contre
l'impérialisme l'impérialisme oui bon et
cette rampe aujourd'hui pour vous c'est
donald trump 0 janvier concernaient il
ressemble tellement donc on a quand on a
fait la version opéra belle était passé
l'autre grand théâtre de québec
on a repris la version 2 et donc les
gens disaient donc c'est et marc
hervieux à marc hervieux qui jouait le
personnage
tous les gens sortent un dixième essai
cette rom vous étiez comme une histoire
avec starmania du skate parenthèses
est-ce qu'on reverra de nouvelle version
de starmania comme on voit des nouvelles
versions notre dame de paris qui me your
une grande production l'année prochaine
c'est là c'est l'anniversaire de du
disque du spectacle cette année mais là
on va faire une grande grande production
tu vas commencer en septembre 19 dans la
lignée l'année même de ces deux noms et
ça va être beau chasser les poissons et
pour réaliser que c'est encore toujours
d'actualité mais notre dame de paris est
aussi toujours d'actualité bon il ya des
millions et des millions de personnes
qui ont vu l'enfant de paris à travers
le monde des millions des millions
d'albums
on devient extraire 9e garou tout à
l'heure mais des sans papiers les
sans-papiers c'était il ya vingt ans
dans un contexte aujourd'hui vous
assistez j'imagine indignés ou
impuissants devant ce qui se passe aux
etats-unis où partout dans le monde avec
les réfugiés sont rendus des millions
oui c'est encore dans notre dame de
paris ces sans papiers
j'ai écrit cette chanson là et ce
tableau là
parce qu'à paris au moment où j'étais en
train d'écrire nos gammes de paris là il
y avait eu lieu dans une église
envahissait de neige passant par une
hausse assez existe un remède à sa
médaille et il n'y avait pas deux cents
200 sans-papiers qui est et s'était
réfugié et puis en principe on pouvait
pas la france et les parts d'une église
existe et pour la première fois dans
mille ans la police française en
français déportés sortie des alpes
c'est alors ça a été très choquant pour
moi et c'est de là que j'ai je
transporte j'ai nommé li lé les sans
papiers est hélas qu'on laisse mourir
des réfugiés des demandeurs d'asile des
gens qui rêvent d'un pays meilleur en
méditerranée quand on dit qu'on sépare
les enfants des parents aux états unis
ça pourrait vous inspirer aussi oui et
chansons et non tu sais très bien que
l'humain est impensable dans un pays
civilisé
un nom depuis que trompe est au pouvoir
on a l'impression que les états unis
vont en redevenir des
un pays de notre demande pas si lisez
quoi de far west avec prêt à tout pour
pour dominer il y avait aussi de très
belles chansons que vous avez composé a
longtemps les de la beauté du monde
ouais c'était parti d'un drame d'une
jungle je ne peux me s'était immolé ici
à montréal
ouais sur la poste jean quartier
jacquard dessus en criant aux aveux tu
es la beauté du moment
mais quand vous voyez encore une fois
c'est aussi ces décès c'est ce qu'on vit
c'est ce qui vous inspire pas ce qui
vous permettent de décrire avec les
ascensions c'est devenu comme un emblème
je l'avais écrite pour venir renée
claude en 73 et rené diane dufresne 80
chanter au forum de montréal sont 1re ch
et aimait et c'est grâce à elle que
c'est devenu un mets ensuite isabelle
voulait la chanter puis elle s'était
retirée avant c'est mais c'est devenu
mon décor elle l'a chanté non j'ai
quelques chansons comme ça qu'ils n'ont
jamais été des rythmes et qui sont plus
forte encore que dès que j'hérite parce
qu'elle sait peut-être comme le parc
belmont c'était jazz au phare dans magna
carrière et ça jamais de jouer à la
radio abc alors notre dame de paris à
l'automne au québec
oui ça arrive là au mois d'août à hawaï
et break 3-1 à québec 5 soir à
trois-rivières et après six semaines
alors vous êtes partout on peut vous
avez opté à deux pas rue de l'auteur de
l'autre avait notre opéra bientôt
peut-être
c'est sur ce on est 2 en cours que je
dois finir bon elle sera espéré par
l'actuel que toujours parce qu'il
déchire comme comme être humain comme
que nous inspire on sort d'un bête
[Rires]
alors le cap le vendeur merci d'être
passé sur notre plateau bonne fête de la
musique à fond l'été pour vous c'est
aussi la fête de la musique merci
beaucoup et de musique à chaque fois
pour moi c'est